hi guys tim ferriss here before we get
started a quick announcement have you
ever wished that you could easily access
the best tips tricks tools and tactics
all that alliteration from 200 plus
guests on the Tim Ferriss show that's
about 600 to 700 hours of audio well now
you can and my new book tools of Titan's
does the job it is an inside look at my
favorite advice from the guest on the
podcast people like Arnold
Schwarzenegger who actually wrote the
foreword for the book Jamie Foxx Tony
Robbins
Peter Thiel Amanda Palmer and so many
others and how you can apply their
wisdom to your life and how I've applied
all their advice to mine is at least 50%
new material new tips from old guests
new tips from brand new guests I poured
my heart into this book so if you love
the podcast you will love tools of
Titan's please check it out it helps me
continue to do this podcast pick up your
copy or just read more about it at tools
of titans dot-com and as always thank
you for listening at this altitude I can
run flat out for a half mile before my
hands start shaking and I all see the
poster question
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by audible which I've
used for years
I love audiobooks and I have to to
recommend right off the bat number one
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and that is the graveyard book by
Neil Gaiman the only audiobook I've
wanted to immediately listen to a second
time as soon as I finished it's amazing
you will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding by ralph pots
which had a huge impact on my life and
formed the basis for a lot of what
became the 4-hour workweek so all you
need to do to get your free 30-day trial
is go to audible.com forward slash tim
TI m and you can choose one of those two
books or you can choose from more great
options than you can possibly imagine so
that could be a book that could be a
magazine that could be a newspaper it
could be a class it's that easy go to
audible.com forward slash Tim that's
audible.com forward slash Tim and grab a
book enjoy this episode is brought to
you by fresh books back in 2003 a busy
freelancer named Mike McDormand I've
actually had dinner with accidentally
saved over an invoice and lost all of
his work to make sure that never
happened again Mike set out to create
fresh books which is now the number one
cloud accounting software designed
exclusively for self-employed
professionals around the world that is
used by now 10 million plus folks in
total who need to send invoices get paid
fast and track their time a lot of you
fall in that category in September of
this year Mike and his entire team
relaunched an all-new version of their
platform built from the ground up double
down on what made a great in the first
place namely simplicity and speed so I
can't cover all the features in this
particular sponsor read but you can set
a branded invoice in under 30 seconds
you can see when a client has looked at
their invoice and you can enable online
payments in two clicks if you need
customer support you will get a real
human being on the phone in 3 rings or
less than their many other things you
can do take pictures of receipts on your
phone using their iOS mobile app and
makes expenses a million times easier
etc etc it is a rad service a lot of you
have recommended to me that's how this
came to be as a sponsorship so to claim
your 30-day unrestricted free trial that
means no credit card needed and see how
the brand-new freshbooks can change your
freelancing game go to freshbooks comm
forward slash tim and enter tim t IM in
the how did you hear about a section
that is first ebooks.com forward slash
tip well this is Tim Ferriss and welcome
to another episode of the Tim Ferriss
show where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers from many
different worlds many different
industries many different areas of
speciality to tease out the philosophies
habits routines etc that you can use
this episode is going to be a little bit
different it is an experimental episode
doing something that many many thousands
of you have requested and that is a
highlight episode but this is not just
material that some of you have heard
this is cherry picked to highlight the
information that I have most applied to
my own life a and B it includes some of
my own commentary for those of you who
are interested and I am inviting back in
the form of his highlight reel and there
many others but this is certainly a
selection that I enjoy Derek Siver's
Derek Siver's who can be found on
Twitter and Facebook at severs si ve RS
he has many many golden nuggets at
sever's org is one of my favorite humans
and I often call him for advice you can
think of him as a philosopher-king
programmer master teacher and of course
merry prankster he's a hilarious guy
originally a professional musician and
circus clown I could do not he did the
latter to counterbalance being
introverted derek created CD Baby in
1998 it became the largest seller of
independent music online with a hundred
million in sales for a hundred and fifty
thousand musicians then in 2008 Derek
sold CD Baby for twenty-two million
dollars giving the proceeds to a
charitable
Trust for music education he is a
frequent speaker at Ted with more than 5
million views of his talks in addition
to publishing 33 books via his company
would egg he is the author of anything
you want which I highly recommend it's a
collection of short life lessons that
I've read personally at least a dozen
times I still have a very early draft
printed out with highlights and notes
behind the scenes Derrick has read
reviewed and ranked ordered more than
200 bucks at sever's org forward slash
books they're automatically sorted from
best to worst he is a huge fan of among
others Charlie Munger Warren Buffett's
business partner and Derek in fact
introduced me to the book seeking wisdom
subtitle from Darwin to Munger by Peter
beveling he read awaken the giant within
by Tony Robbins who's also been on this
podcast and if I mention any past guests
you can find all their episodes at
4-hour workweek dot-com forward slash
podcast but he read awaken the giant
within by Tony Robbins when he was 18
and it changed his life I posted the
following on Facebook when I was in fact
working on this chapter from my new book
tools of Titans and it read as follows
quote I might need to do a second volume
of my next book 100% dedicated to the
knowledge bombs of Derek severs so much
good stuff hard to cut end quote
there are many comments that float in
the most up voted comment was from agent
named Kevin O who said quote put a link
to the podcast and have them listen it's
less than two hours and it will change
their life Tim you and Derek got me from
call center worker to location
independent freelancer with more
negotiation power for income and
benefits than I previously imagined you
both also taught me the value of enough
and contentment and appreciation in
addition to achievement so that made my
week and I do highly recommend everybody
listen to the whole episodes and there
are more than one with Derek but
especially the first and of course you
can find that at four-hour work week
comm forward slash Derek but moving on
if more information was the answer that
we'd all be billionaires with perfect
abs this is a direct quote from Sir
Derek and it really underscores that
it's not what you know it's what you do
consistently and 20 Robbins just to
bring him up since I did already has
said something along the lines of what
you know doesn't mean [ __ ] it's what you
do consistently that makes the
difference it's not about just more
how-to information it's about why to
incentives and much more than that so
it's not just enough to ingest more
pages and so on you have to put it into
practice and you have to rig the game so
you can win by creating incentives which
I've talked about a lot in the disent
stakes section of the 4-hour chef but
you can use tools like stick stic kk
comm or something like coach taught me
how to thrive in an unknowable future
choose to plan with the most options the
best plan is the one that lets you
change your plans my commentary this is
one of Derek's directives as he calls
them which are his one-line rules for
life distilled from hundreds of books
and decades of lessons learned other
directives of his include be expensive
which I think certainly echoes the
sentiment of Marc Andreessen who's been
on the podcast expect disaster which
echoes one of my favorite podcast guests
he's only 2,000 years old Seneca I've
had him on before my favorite stoic
philosopher and owned as little as
possible which echoes other podcast
guests including Jason Nemer
and Kevin Kelly in fact
who do you think of when you hear the
word successful well the first answer to
any question isn't much fun because it's
just automatic right like what's the
first painting that comes to mind Mona
Lisa hello name a genius
Einstein who's a composer Mozart but
this is the subject of the book Thinking
Fast and Slow by Daniel Kahneman there's
the instant unconscious automatic
thinking and then there's the slower
conscious rational deliberate thinking
so I'm really really into the slower
thinking like breaking my automatic
responses to the things in my life and
slowly thinking through a more
deliberate response instead and then for
the things in life for an automatic
response is useful I can create a new
one consciously so like what if you
asked when you think of the word
successful who's the third person that
comes to mind and why are they actually
more successful than the first person
that came to mind well in that case the
first person would be Richard Branson
because he's like the stereotype right
he's like the Mona Lisa of success to me
and honestly you might be my second
answer but we could talk about that a
different time and my third and real
answer after thinking it through is that
we can't know without knowing a person's
aims right like what if Richard Branson
set out to live a quiet life but like a
compulsive gambler he just can't stop
creating companies well then that
changes everything and we can't really
call him successful anymore
my commentary this is absolutely genius
I love this approach and it is not
limited to Derek Ricardo Semler CEO and
majority owner of the Brazilian based
Senco Partners who's writing I've read
quite a bit of early on just after
graduating from college practice is
asking why three times this is true when
he is questioning his own motives doing
self work so to speak or when tackling
big projects and collaborating with
others the rationale is identical to
Derek's
for people starting out say yes when
Derrick was 18 he lived in Boston and he
attended the Berklee College of Music
I'm in this band where the bass player
one day in rehearsal says hey man my
agent just offered me a gig
it's like $75 to play at a pig show in
Vermont he rolls his eyes and he's like
I'm not gonna do it do you want the gig
I'm like [ __ ] yeah a paying gig oh my
god yes so I took the gig to go up to
Burlington Vermont and I think it was
like a you know $58 round-trip bus
ticket and I get to this pig show in
Vermont I strap my acoustic guitar and
then I walk around a pig show playing
music and did that for like three hours
got on the bus home and the next day the
booking agent called me up and said uh
hey so well yo you did a really good job
at the pig show we got good reports
there um wondering if you can come play
at an art opening in western
Massachusetts oh I'll pay you 75 bucks
again yeah sure it's the same thing I
took the you know like a $60 bus out to
Western Massachusetts got 75 bucks for
playing at an art opening
and the agent was there and he was
impressed and so he said hey look I've
got this circus and the previous
musician just quit so we really need
somebody new and I really like what
you're doing so there's a about three
gigs a week I can pay you 75 bucks a gig
they're usually Friday Saturday Sunday
do you want the gig I said hell yeah I'm
a professional musician now this is
amazing so so I said yes to everything
which is gonna come up later you know
with the hell yeah or no thing but I
think it's really smart to switch
strategies but when you're earlier in
your career I think the best strategies
you just say yes to everything every
pretty little gig you just never know
what are the lottery tickets so this one
ended up being a real lottery ticket for
me
the standard paces for chumps Kimmel
Williams is this large black man from
Hawaii and that was a musician that
attended Berklee School of Music and
then stayed there to teach for a while
and so what he taught me in four lessons
got me to graduate Berklee College of
Music in half the time it would take and
here was his thing he said the reason I
wanted you to like study with me for a
bit he said I know you only have like
eight weeks before you go to school he
said I think you can graduate Berklee
School of Music in two years instead of
four he said the standard pace is for
chumps I should get a t-shirt made for
that he's the one at the age of like
1718 got me into this mentality said
where the standard pace is for chumps
that's the school has to organize its
curricula around the lowest common
denominator so that almost nobody is
left out so they have to slow down so
that everybody can catch up but he said
you're smarter than that or anybody can
be smarter than that if they want to be
so you can go as fast as you want and
here's how and so he sat me down at the
piano he said okay what do you know
about music theory I said well I don't
know let's find out and he you know you
just asked me a few of these music
questions like okay what how does it
major scale go did it doctor done right
okay show me the tritone do you know
what a tritone is okay play me a tritone
in the C major scale I'm like okay be an
F he said okay now how can you take that
and what other chord can you make from
be enough he said okay that's called the
substitute chord now what is the
resolution we realize and he was just
like don't don't film it this kind of
pace he was doing all this music theory
stuff with me it was so intense and I
was like I had all this adrenaline like
a video game was like this is amazing
okay keep going
okay and that was like a two-hour lesson
that went at that kind of pace and then
he dumped a bunch of homework on me he
said okay now go home tonight and take
this big book of jazz standards find me
all the to five substitutions four to
five closures now substitute chords for
that and then come back next Thursday
and we'll do this again so we did that
for like for Thursday's in a row and
sure enough what he taught
in four two-hour sessions was basically
like two years of Berklee College of
Music he compressed it into four head
lessons Wow so that when I showed up to
my first day of Berklee I tested out of
the first few years just thanks to him
and then he even taught me a strategy
just deep off hand mentioned he said you
know I think they might still have a
rule in place where those other required
courses you know that you have to take
to graduate he said I think you could
pretty much just buy the books for those
and then contact the department head and
just take the final exam to get credit
don't be a doggie what advice would you
give your thirty year old self my advice
to my thirty year old self would be um
don't be a donkey well I mean a lot of
thirty year olds that are trying to
pursue many different directions at once
but not making progress in any right and
then or or they get frustrated that the
world wants them to pick one thing
because they want to do them all and I
get a lot of this frustration like but I
want to do this and that and this and
that why do I have to choose I don't
know what to choose but the problem is
if you're thinking short term then
you're acting as if you don't do them
all this week that they won't happen but
I think the solution is to think long
term to realize that you can do one of
these things for a few years and then do
another one for a few years and then
another so what I mean about don't be a
donkey is you've probably heard of the
fable about I think it's buried in stunk
II whoo it's a fable about a donkey that
is standing halfway in between a pile of
hay and a bucket of water and he just
keeps looking left to the hay a right to
the water trying to decide hey or water
hey our water he's unable to decide so
he eventually falls over and dies of
both hunger and thirst so the point is
that a donkey can't think of the future
if he did he'd clearly realized that he
could just go first drink the water and
then go eat the hay so my advice to my
30 year old self is
don't be a donkey that you can do
everything you want to do you just need
foresight and patience business models
can be simple you don't need to
constantly pivot Derek tells the story
of the sophisticated origins of CD B hey
B's business model and pricing so I was
living in Woodstock New York at the time
and there was a cute tiny little record
store in town that sold consignment CDs
on the counter of local musicians so I
walked it in there one day and I said
hey um how does it work if I want to
sell my CD here and she said well you
set the selling price whatever you want
we just keep a flat $4.00 per CD sold
and then just come by every week and
we'll pay you so I went home to my new
website that night and I wrote you set
your selling price at whatever you want
we just keep a flat $4 per CD sold and
we'll pay you every week and then I
realized that it took about 45 minutes
of time for me to set up a new album
into the system because I had to you
know lay the album art on the scanner in
Photoshop it and crop it and then fix
them the musicians spelling mistakes in
their own bio and all that kind of stuff
I took about 45 minutes of work per
album so it shows you what I was valuing
my time at those days but I thought 45
minutes of my time that's worth about 25
bucks
so I'll charge a $25 setup fee to sign
up for this thing and then ooh at the
last minute I thought wait a second in
my mind 25 and 35 they hold that they're
in the same like brain cell in my head
25 and 35 those numbers don't feel very
different when it comes to cost you know
like $10 is different and $50 is
different but 25 35 that occupies the
same space in the mind so you know what
I'm gonna make it 35 that will let me
give anyone a discount anytime they ask
you know even if somebody's on the phone
and up settle so you know what let me
give you a discount
in that little buffer so I could give
people a discount which they love so
yeah
$35 setup fee $4 per CD sold and the Tim
for the next 10 years that was it that
was my in the Haier business model you
know which was generated in five minutes
by walking down to the local record
store and asking what they do
[Music]
once you have some success if it's not a
hell yes it's a no this mantra of
Derrick's quickly became one of my
favorite rules of thumb I apply it all
over the place and it led me to take in
effect at this point certainly an
indefinite startup vacation which
started in late 2015 I've elaborated on
that in the past in my blog post which
was how to say no when it matters most
but here is his origins during how he
arrived at the if it's not a hell yes
it's a no and then once it came closed
it was like time to book the ticket I
was like I don't really want to go to
Australia right now I'm busy with other
stuff and it was actually my friend
amber Rue Barth who's a brilliant
musician I was on the phone with her and
kind of lamenting about this and she's
the one that pointed out she said it
sounds like you know from where you're
at your decision is not between yes and
no you need to figure out whether you're
feeling like [ __ ] yeah or no and I said
yeah that's that's really what it comes
down to right cuz the idea is if you're
feeling anything less than like oh hell
yeah I would love to do that oh my god
that would be amazing
if you're feeling anything less than
that then just say no because most of us
say yes to too much stuff and then we
let these little mediocre things fill
our lives and so the problem is when
that occasional big oh my god hell yeah
thing comes along you don't have enough
time to give it the attention that you
should because you've said yes to too
much other little half-assed kind of
stuff right so once I started applying
this my life just opened up
busy equals out-of-control every time
people contact you every time people
come tact me they say you know look I
know you must be incredibly busy and
always think like no I'm not because
because I'm in control of my time I'm on
top of it busy to me seems to imply like
out of control you know like oh my god
I'm so busy I don't have any time for
this yet that's to me that sounds like a
person who's got no control of their
life my commentary lack of time is lack
of priorities if I personally am busy
and I'm inclined to say busy and answer
the how are you question that way it's
because I've made choices that put me in
that position so I've forbidden myself
to reply to how are you with busy I have
no right to complain and if that is the
case if I am too busy instead it's a cue
to re-examine my systems and rules to
additional 80/20 analysis and so on that
I've talked about ad nauseam before what
would you put on the billboard
I really admire those places like I
think Vermont and Sao Paulo Brazil that
ban billboards but I know that that
wasn't really what you were asking so so
my better answer is I think I would make
a billboard that would say
won't make you happy and I would place
it outside any big shopping mall or car
dealer so ideally actually I think you
know what be fun project is to buy and
train thousands of parrots to say it
won't make you happy it won't make you
happy and then you let them loose in the
shopping malls and super stores in other
words again anybody with me let's do it
take 45 minutes instead of 43 is your
red face worth it so yeah I've always
been very type A and so a friend of mine
got me into cycling when I was living in
LA and I lived right on the beach in
Santa Monica where there's this great
bike path in the sand that goes for I
think it's 25 miles in ass and uh 20
foot know hold on something like that
the exact number doesn't matter but what
I would do is I would go onto the bike
path and I would get like head down and
push it as hard as I could I would go
all the way to one end of the bike path
and back and then back home and I'd set
my little timer when doing this huffing
and puffing red face just red face
huffing it but like just pushing it as
hard as I can every single you know
thrust of the leg just and of course you
know that made me quite fun if somebody
was in my way on the bike path sure that
guy's got places to go so but I noticed
it was always 43 minutes I mean you know
if you know Santa Monica California you
know the weather is about exactly the
same all year round
so unless it was a surprisingly windy
day it was always 43 minutes is what it
took me to go as fast as I could for
that on that bike path but I noticed
that over time I was starting to feel
less psyched about going out on the bike
path cuz just mentally when I would
think of it it would feel like pain and
hard work yeah it was but you know I
guess at first that was okay and after a
while I just felt like I don't know
running the bike why don't I just hang
out so then I say you know that's no
that's not cool for me to start to
associate negative stuff with going on
why don't I just chill for once like I'm
just gonna go on the same bike ride but
just you know I'm not gonna be a
complete snail but I'll go at like half
of my normal pace so yeah I got on my
bike and it was just Pleasant I just
went on the same bike ride but more like
standing up and I just noticed that I
was I was looking around more and and I
looked out in the ocean I noticed there
was that day there were these dolphins
jumping in the ocean and and I went down
to Marina del Rey to my turnaround point
and oh no actually it was when the The
Breakers at Marina del Rey there was a
penguin that was flying above me I was
like no way looked up was like hey a
penguin and come he [ __ ] in my mouth
was it a penguin or a pelican
oh sorry Pelican like what did you take
before you're right see it a pelican
sorry all I can [ __ ] in your mouth what
was that's incredible accuracy was that
from like how far away was it uh 20 feet
up Wow because I I don't know if he was
accurate or I was you know it is I had
such a nice time it was just purely
Pleasant there was no red face there was
no huffing and puffing I was just
cycling it was nice and when I got back
to my usual stopping place I looked at
my watch and it said 45 minutes and I
was like no way how the hell could that
have been 45 minutes as compared to my
usual 43 it's like there's no way but
yeah it was right 45 minutes and that
was like a profound lesson that I think
changed the way I've approached my life
ever since is because I realized that I
guess you know what percentage of that
huffing and puffing then we could do the
math or whatever I would add 93 points
and something present of my huffing and
puffing and all that red-faced and all
that stress was only for an extra two
minutes it was basically for nothing I
mean you know of course we're not
talking about me competing in something
where the huffing and puffing might have
been worth it but for life I think of
all of this
optimization and getting the maximum
dollar out of everything in the maximum
out of every second of the maximum out
of every minute and I think I just take
this approach now of going like or you
could just take the lesson take most of
that lesson and apply it and be
effective and be happy but you don't
need to stress about any of this stuff
and so honestly that's been my approach
ever since I do things but I stopped it
before anything gets stressful is there
any particular way that you remind
yourself of that given a lifetime of
hard charging if I I would find I do
find that I sometimes lose track of that
type of truth which i think is a truth
in almost every aspect of the endeavours
that I partake in at least are there any
particular ways that you remind yourself
of that or keep it present for you I
think it's just noticing the pain I
luckily I live in a world where I
there's more psychic pain than physical
pain right so you have to notice the
psychic pain that you're feeling of
whether it's doing things you don't want
to be doing and feeling the pain and
regret of that or the frustration just
when you notice this internal error that
always that's my cue that I treat that
like physical pain of like what am i
doing would I need to stop doing that
thing that hurts what is that and it
usually means that I'm just pushing too
hard or doing things that I don't really
want to be doing because I was asking
the wrong questions and following the
wrong yeah following the wrong path the
wrong outcome
on lack of morning routines not only do
I not have morning rituals but there's
really nothing that I do every day
except for you know eating or some form
of writing but here's why I get really
really really into one thing at a time
for example a a year ago I discovered a
new approach to programming my
PostgreSQL database that made all of my
code a lot easier so I spent five months
like every waking hour just completely
immersed into this one thing I would
bounce outta bed at 5:00 in the morning
and programming SQL code for like 19
hours from 5:00 a.m. till midnight
you know I'd stopped maybe an hour at
2:00 a day to go for a run or talk on
the phone with a friend but after five
months I finished that project so I took
a week and I went hiking in Milford
Sound in New Zealand totally offline but
when I got back from that I was so like
Zen nature boy that I spent the next
couple weeks just reading books outside
what's something you believe that other
people think is crazy oh that's easy
I've got a lot of unpopular opinions I
believe alcohol tastes bad and so do
olives I've never tried coffee but I
don't like the smell I believe all
audiobooks should be read and recorded
by people from Iceland because they've
got the best accent I believe it would
be wonderful to move to a new country
every six months for the rest of my life
I believe you shouldn't start a business
unless people are asking you to I
believe I'm below average it's a
deliberate cultivated belief to
compensate for our tendency to think
we're above average
I believe the movie Scott Pilgrim is a
masterpiece I believe that music and
people don't mix that music should be
appreciated alone without seeing or
knowing who the musicians are and
without other people around so just
listening to music for its own sake not
listening to the people around you and
not filtered through what you know about
the musicians personal life
treat life is a series of experiments so
my recommendation is to do little tests
like try a few months of living the life
you think you want but leave yourself an
exit plan being open to the chance the
big chance that you might not like it
after actually trying it the best book
about this subject is stumbling on
happiness by Daniel Gilbert his
recommendation is to talk to a few
people that are currently where you
think you want to be and ask them for
the pros and cons and then trust their
opinions since they're right in it not
just remembering or imagining even when
everything is going terribly and I have
no reason to be confident I just decide
to be there's this beautiful Kurt
Vonnegut quote that's just a throwaway
line in the middle of one of his books
that says you are whatever you pretend
to be the most successful email Derek
ever wrote at its largest Derek spent
roughly four hours on CD Baby every six
months four hours every six months he
had systematized everything to run
without him
Derek is both successful end fulfilled
because he never hesitates to challenge
the status quo to test assumptions to
question legacy belief systems or any
type of system really that others are
saying he should use it doesn't have to
take all that much to test these
assumptions or to do a lot with a little
and the following email which is his
most successful email he ever wrote
illustrates this beautifully and I'm
going to read what he is written about
it and the email itself enter Derek when
you make a business you're making a
little world where you control the laws
it doesn't matter how things are done
everywhere else in your little world
you can make it like it should be when I
first built C GB but keep in mind I'm
speaking into Eric's voice when I first
built CD Baby every order had an
automated email that let the customer
know when the CD was at
we shipped at first there's just the
normal your order has shipped today
please let us know if it doesn't arrive
thank you for your business after a few
months that felt really incongruent with
my mission to make people smile side
note from Tim Ferriss this is very true
Derek takes making people smile very
seriously feels pretty good job I think
- back to Derek I knew I could do better
so I took 20 minutes and wrote this
goofy little thing this is the email
your CD has been gently taken from our
CD baby shelves with sterilized
contamination free gloves and placed
onto a satin pillow a team of 50
employees inspected your CD and polished
it to make sure it was in the best
possible condition before mailing our
packing specialist from Japan lit a
candle and a hush fell over the crowd as
he put your CD into the finest gold
lined box that money can buy we all had
a wonderful celebration afterwards and
the whole party marched down the street
to the post office where the entire town
of Portland waved bum by oz to your
package on its way to you in our private
CD baby jet on this day friday june 6 i
hope you had a wonderful time shopping
at CD baby we sure did your pictures on
the wall as customer of the year we're
all exhausted but can't wait for you to
come back to in all-caps cdbaby.com
- exclamation points that one silly
email sent out with every order has been
so loved that if you search google for
private CD baby jet you will get more
than 20,000 results each of those
results each one is somebody who got the
email and loved it enough to post it on
their website and tell all of their
friends that one goofy email created
thousands of new customers when you're
thinking of how to make your business
bigger it's tempting to try to think all
the big thoughts the world changing
massive action plans but please know
that it's often the tiny details that
really thrill someone enough to make
them tell all of their friends about you
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday the vet provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour workweek com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books back in 2003 a busy freelancer
named Mike McDermott
but I've actually had dinner with
accidentally saved over an invoice and
lost all of his work to make sure that
never happened again Mike set out to
create fresh books which is now the
number one cloud accounting software
designed exclusively for self-employed
professionals around the world that is
used by now 10 million plus folks in
total who need to send invoices get paid
fast and track their time a lot of you
fall in that category in September of
this year Mike and his entire team
relaunched an all new version of their
platform built from the ground up double
down on what made a great in first place
namely simplicity and speed so I can't
cover all the features in this
particular sponsor read but you can set
a branded invoice in under 30 seconds
you can see when a client has looked at
their invoice and you can enable online
payments in two clicks if you need
customer support you will get a real
human being on the phone in 3 rings or
less and there many other things you
think pictures of receipts on your phone
using their iOS mobile app
and makes expenses a million times
easier etc etc it is a rad service a lot
of you have recommended to me that's how
this came to be as a sponsorship so to
claim your 30-day unrestricted free
trial that means no credit card needed
and see how the brand-new FreshBooks can
change your freelancing game go to
freshbooks comm forward slash Tim and
enter Tim T I am in the how did you hear
about a section that is fresh books comm
forward slash tip this episode is
brought to you by audible which I've
used for years I love audiobooks and I
have to to recommend right off the bat
number one is pressed my favorite
audiobook of all time and that is the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman the only
audiobook I wanted to immediately listen
to a second time as soon as I finished
it's amazing
you will thank me the graveyard book the
second is vagabonding by Roth pots which
had a huge impact on my life
and form the basis for a lot of what
became the 4-hour workweek so all you
need to do to get your free 30-day trial
is go to audible.com forward slash tim t
IM and you can choose one of those two
books or you can choose from more great
options than you can possibly imagine so
that could be a book that could be a
magazine that can be a newspaper it
could be a class it's that easy go to
audible.com forward slash Tim that's
audible.com forward slash Tim and grab a
book enjoy
you